last question I'm really interested to
get your view on is how popular is Boris
Johnson uh not very I think let's let's
just be frank two out of three people
think he's lied and misled Parliament
and when we asked people which were the
which prime minister they think did a
good job or a bad job Boris Johnson tops
the bad job list by some margin he does
have a you know a minority of people who
are still fans but it's much smaller
than some of his back benches think
quite frankly I mean this is what you
were just mentioning about did he lie
did the sports Johnson Mr Lee Parliament
65 saying he did yeah which is a big
number it is exactly and but remember I
think Boris Johnson did always get a
free pass in many ways even before he
became prime minister
um many more people thought he was
untrustworthy and didn't tell the truth
than did and it just got worse from
there so
um some of that sort of priced in and I
think that's the key Point Boris Johnson
does strange things and accuses
parliament of Kangaroo Court Etc
for a lot of people they're just going
to say next and
you about Boris Johnson's popularity
versus Russia Cena I think we can have a
quick look at some of the research that
you've done on this so this is Boris
Johnson investors British Cenac who do
you think would be a better pm and the
kind of dark blue line there is
effectively the student numbers so 28
all voters say he would be a better PM
compared to 17 say Boris Johnson
including actually the 2019 conservative
voters yes so even among conservative
voters the dwindling band of
conservative voters many more say that
sunac would be a better prime minister
than Johnson so I think in many ways you
would say on that on the basis of that
his um his time is over in politics for
the moment that's really interesting uh
to hear because you know Boris Johnson's
resignation letter when I left office
last year the government was only a few
handful of points behind the polls he
will save points the fact he won the
biggest majority in almost half a
century the majority is clearly at risk
what'd you say to that argument
um he was already very unpopular by the
time he he left office and the Trump you
know the likelihood of him winning uh as
prime minister is less likely than sunak
to be quite honest so
um you know yes he's got a lot he has
some supporters but really his you know
his time all political careers end in
Failure uh and you start as maybe
popular and end up unpopular but uh his
trajectory is pretty dramatic I would
anyone go into politics that's one
reason I never have I'm
uh I am also very interested to know
what is going on with these violations
that are coming out because we've got
three by-elections coming up it feels to
me like the most interesting is probably
that one of Boris Johnson's concert
absolutely
so the 7 000 majority this if if if
um starmer is going to win a general
election convincingly this ought to be
in many ways a breeze for labor and they
have held the seat as recently as the
1960s or you know in that particular
part but that's that's really is going
to be an acid test if that if they
Breeze through that then all the polls
showing on average 16-point lead for
labor people will bake it in if they
don't or it's only a very narrow win I
think there will be a lot more
uncertainty and then we come on to the
lib Dems chances in the dean dory's seat
in mid beds where again they might do it
it's a huge majority 24 and a half
thousand but they've done things like
that before in amersham it does require
my labor in that seat to really stand
down because if you look at the amersham
vote by election I think labor got fewer
votes than in virtually any election
only 600 people in amersham actually
voted labor wow in that by-election so
it requires a fair amount of tactical
voting and I think the challenge in this
situation as we approach as we're now
much closer to a general election is is
labor going to really stand aside to
give the um you know to give everybody a
chance that's really interesting because
Ed Davey's gone to the seeds and to be
honest I had a look at this this is the
tablet here this is what happened last
time yeah you can see the lib Dems in
third place I was like
that's optimistic isn't it from the lib
Dems are they you know but maybe you're
right maybe there was a bit of tactical
voting yes things could change that
that's probably their best Prospect and
then we go on to of course
where again you know a big swing needed
it's it's actually gone more and more
Tori over the last few elections with
Nigel Adams uh again you'd want to see
some really good progress there by labor
maybe the liberal Democrats decide not
to bother too much there and uh leave it
to labor to have a go who knows but
again you'll be looking for signs
everybody will be looking for signs that
labor really is delivering on the ground
uh I guess the conservatives just hope
to get this all over and done with as
quickly as possible fascinating is there
a landing Zone finally for Russia Scenic
do you think at the general elections
well I mean the conservatives are
currently on 28 percentage points one of
the rules of British politics is that
you can put a parrot on a stick and it
should if it's standing for labor or the
conservatives get around 29 30 percent
the vote Jeremy corbyn I thought was
going to break this rule in 2017 because
he started off the general election
campaign on 26 percent but lo and behold
he was steamed past that number so
nobody you know this will be unknown
territory if if this happens it will
also be unknown territory though for
Kirsten if he becomes prime minister
because his personal ratings are some of
the lowest for any leader of the
opposition who looks like they're going
to win a general election he's not
particularly popular as an individual
but maybe now we're fed up with
excitement and Charisma and we just want
something else it's absolutely
fascinating you know it's been really
interesting to talk I feel like I've
learned an awful lot from this
conversation so thank you very much for
coming on pleasure thank you